le problème le plus prestigieux de
l'informatique et le problème pv reçus
cnp qui est aussi l'un des sept
problèmes du millénaire comme
l'expliquent patience dans cette vidéo
et sciences étonnant dans cette autre
vidéo
en gros ce problème demande si tout
puzzle dont la réponse peut être
vérifier facilement est aussi facile à
résoudre
aujourd'hui on va voir la piste
dominante proposé à ce jour pour
résoudre le problème pv reçus cnp qui
s'appelle la théorie de la complexité
géométrique et que l'informaticien scott
aronson appelle la théorie des cordes de
l'informatique
cette théorie a été introduite par les
informaticiens kettane mulet et me line
sauroni dans les années 90 mais alors
pourquoi la théorie des cordes de
l'informatique et bien d'un côté les
outils mathématiques utilisés ont des
similarités avec la théorie des cordes
mais surtout la combinaison entre
élégance mathématiques prétention à être
ultra fondamentale et degré spéculatifs
est très similaire au cas de la théorie
des cordes en physique ainsi qu'à ta
bulle mulet l'un des fondateurs de la
théorie a affirmé que si elle est viable
la complexité algorithmique pourrait
réussir à résoudre paix versus np d'ici
environ 100 ans
bon comme vous l'imaginez expliquer la
complexité géométrique
c'est au moins aussi compliquée que
d'expliquer la théorie des cordes il est
ainsi hors de question que je vous
propose quelque chose de très rigoureuse
je vais tenter d'être un peu
compréhensible si vous voulez en savoir
plus je vous invite à lire ce super
article de scott aronson sur lequel sa
vidéo se repose ceci étant dit je ne
veux pas non plus avoir le courage
d'avoir le niveau de vulgarisation des
physiciens l'épisode du coup va quand
même un peu piqué
bon pour commencer je vais vous rappeler
en quoi consiste le problème des versus
np en gros il revient à demander si des
problèmes donc on peut vérifier la
solution rapidement peuvent être résolus
rapidement la plupart des informaticiens
pense que paix est différent de mp ce
qui veut dire que certains problèmes
donc vérifier la solution est facile
sont difficiles à résoudre et le sudoku
ou casser les codes bancaires sont des
exemples vraiment typique de cette tâche
de tels problèmes dont vérifier la
solution est facile sont appelés des
problèmes np mais pour aujourd'hui je
vais les appeler des problèmes type
sudoku et ce n'est pas par hasard
puisque le sudoku en particulier qu'on
tient en un sens toutes les difficultés
des problèmes
np de façon un peu plus précise le
problème p versus np se demande s'il
existe un unique algorithme qui résout
rapidement tous les problèmes de type
sudoku quelle que soit la taille des
sudokus à résoudre et malheureusement
l'ensemble de tels algorithme est
extrêmement difficile à étudier certains
chercheurs ont ainsi proposé d'autoriser
de change et d'algorithmes pour chaque
taille de sudoku on parle d'algorithmes
non uniforme
la version non uniforme de paix versus
impe et est alors le problème ps lâche
poli versus np ou ps lâche poli et
l'ensemble des algorithmes qu'on peut
résoudre rapidement en s'autorisant
d'orgueil de l'algorithme de résolution
en fonction de la taille du problème à
résoudre les avantages de paix slash
poli et qu'on peut interpréter les
algorithmes de cette classe plus
facilement en termes de suite de
circuits logiques pour rappel un circuit
logique est une suite d'opérations en
forme de graphe qui part de données
binaires initial qui les combines avec
des portes logiques et où ou non et qui
conclut avec des résultats binaire fine
en étant donné un circuit logique ainsi
dessinée on peut alors calculer la
fonction déterminée par le circuit
logique en regardant quelles sont ses
sorties pour les différentes valeurs
possibles des entrées dans le cas des
deux circuits logiques à l'écran on voit
que pour l'entrée 00 le circuit ressort
un et un pour l'entrée 1 0 il ressort un
un vol entre et 0,1 et au sort 0-0 et
pour l'entrée 1 1 et au sort 1 1 comme
les sorties sont les mêmes quelle que
soit les entrées les deux circuits
logiques calcul en fait la même fonction
qui correspond aussi à l'implication
logique y un pic x
une solution ps l'âge police est alors
équivalentes à une suite de circuits
logiques tels que lorsqu'on lui donne la
taille du dock ou à résoudre
il va choisir le circuit logique qui
définit les calculs à effectuer pour
cette taille de sudoku et comme les
calculs doivent être rapides le circuit
logique ainsi obtenus doivent lui être
petit dans ce sens où le nombre de
portes logiques utilisé peut être
polynomiale ans la taille du sudoku
en effet le nombre d'opérations du
circuit logique n'est autre que le
nombre de portes logiques utilisé
clairement on sait que paix est inclus
dans ps lâche poli puisque ps lâche paul
y revient à s'autoriser plus de choses
que dans paix en particulier si on
arrive à démontrer que le sudoku ne peut
pas être résolue par des solutions ps
lâche pauli alors on en déduira
immédiatement que le sudoku ne peut pas
être résolue par des algorithmes p ainsi
pour prouver paix différent de np il
suffit en fait de démontrer qu'il
n'existe pas de famille de circuits
logiques de taille raisonnable capable
de résoudre des sudoku
alors malheureusement les m
opérateur et ou et non ne sont pas ultra
jolies elles sont jolies mais ne sont
pas aussi sophistiqué que les
mathématiques de la multiplication et de
l'addition pour lesquelles on a les
théories vraiment remarquable à savoir
la théorie des polynômes à plusieurs
variables nous encore dispose de
nombreuses interprétations géométriques
spectaculaire de tels polynôme qui ont
donné lieu à ce qu'on appelle désormais
la théorie de la géométrie algébrique
cette géométrie algébrique s'est
d'ailleurs retrouvé au coeur de
nombreuses théories fondamentales de la
physique et en particuler la théorie des
cordes
l'idée de la complexité géométrique est
justement de s'appuyer sur la géométrie
algébrique pour mieux comprendre les
limites des circuits logiques et pour
cela la complexité géométrique propose
de s'intéresser non pas aux circuits
logiques nouveau circuit arithmétique
ces circuits arithmétique prennent
incité nombre et les combines 2 à 2 avec
des portes arithmétique qui peuvent être
l'addition ou la multiplication par
exemple la fonction à au carré + 2 ab
plus becquart et correspond à un circuit
arithmétique avec deux entrées a et b
avec une première porte multiplicatif
qui combinent à et à une seconde porte
multiplicatif qui combine aa2 une
troisième porte multiplicatif qui
combine le résultat de la seconde porte
à b et une quatrième porte multiplicatif
qui combine b&b
puis on a une porte a dit yves qui
combine le résultat de la première porte
aux résultats de la troisième et enfin
une porte a dit yves qui combine le
résultat de la première portative aux
résultats de la quatrième porte
multiplicatif la théorie de la
complexité arithmétique valeurs
typiquement se demander si cette
fonction on a pu être effectué avec
moins de portes
aït meetic que les six portes convient
d'utiliser bien d'autres cas il se
trouve que la fonction calculée est
aussi à gala a + b au carré qui peut se
calculer avec deux portes seulement à
savoir une première qui additionnent a
et b une seconde qui multiplie les
résultats de la première porte par
lui-même
le problème le plus prestigieux de la
complexité arithmétique est une
conjecture énoncées par le prix turing
leslie vaillante en 1979 qu'on appelle
désormais la conjecture de vaillantes
cette conjecture porte sur la différence
entre deux opérateurs appelé le
déterminant et le permanent étant donné
une matrice c'est-à-dire un tableau de
nombres le permanent se calcule en
considérant toutes les façons de
sélectionner exactement un nombre par
ligne et par colonne et en multipliant
les nombreux sélectionnés puis le
permanent additionne tous les résultats
obtenus ainsi lutter terminant lui ce
calcul comme le permanent à la simple
différence près qu'on met un signe
négatif lorsque la sélection d'un nombre
par ligne et par colonne à ce qu'on
appelle une signature négative
je veux pas rentrer dans les détails de
ce que ça signifie mais je vais juste
vous dire que ça a à voir avec la parité
du mélange eau m on parle du cas
lyonnais dans cette vidéo
bref le permanent est le déterminant
sont deux fonctions a priori très
similaires par ailleurs le circuit
arithmétique naïve pour calculer ses
fonctions est très compliqué il faut au
moins une porte par façon de
sélectionner un nombre par ligne et par
colonne pour une matrice n par l île i
am factorielle façon de faire cette
sélection ce qui est absolument énorme
quand on n est supérieur à 100 par
exemple ceci dit on peut démontrer qu'il
existe des façons efficaces de calculer
le déterminant par exemple en utilisant
l'algorithme de go ce jour dans le
déterminant a en fait une faible
complexité arithmétique il peut se
calculer facilement avec des circuits
ait meetic est bien la conjecture de
vaillantes postule que ce n'est pas le
cas du permanent
cette conjecture postule que le
permanent nécessité des opérations
algébrique déraisonnable pour être
calculé exactement
d'un point de vue algébrique cette
conjecture paraît très étrange
après tout algébrique mans le permanent
est le déterminant ne diffère que de
façon minime presque anecdotique
l'un fait intervenir un signe négatif en
plus pour la moitié des termes
additionnés cependant la distinction
entre le permanent est le déterminant
paraît plus clair sur le plan
géométrique de façon intrigante à une
constante multiplicatif près chacun est
entièrement déterminée par l'ensemble de
ces symétrie en particulier le
déterminant dispose de symétrie que le
permanent n'a pas pour être précis il
est un variant par des déformations par
n'importe quel matrice dont le produit
des déterminants et
alors que pour être un variant vis-à-vis
de cette transformation le permanent
nécessite le fait que ces matrices doit
être diagnostiquée plus restrictif et du
coût correspond à moins de symétrie la
complexité géométrique cherche alors à
exploiter ces symétrie pour démontrer la
conjecture de vaillantes et ses
généralisations dans l'espoir que des
généralisations de la conjecture de
vaillantes implique un possibilité de
résoudre des problèmes de sudoku avec
des circuits logiques de taille
raisonnable
la conjecture central de la complexité
géométrique correspond à une astuce qui
permettrait de mettre les considérations
de complexité arithmétique et
algorithmique pour sera menée ainsi un
problème qui est entièrement un problème
de géométrie algébrique le problème en
question consiste à déterminer dans
quelle mesure le permanent peut être vu
comme une forme de déterminant des
formes et la conjecture dit de mulmilla
sony postule que cette façon de voir le
permanent comme déterminant déformé
n'est tenable que si les normes matrix
et exponentiellement plus grande que la
matrice initial
si l'observation crucial de mule mulet
sony c'est que si leur conjectures est
vrai alors la conjecture de valiante est
vrai aussi
autrement dit de façon remarquable les
propriétés algébrique qui lie les petits
permanent aux grands déterminant
déformés ou des implications majeures
sur la complexité arithmétique du
permanent dont on espère ensuite se
servir pour démontrer l'impossibilité de
résoudre rapidement des sudokus mulet et
sony ont réussi à aller plus loin encore
et a ramené la conjecture de muets sony
à une condition suffisante sur des
objets typiques de la géométrie
algébrique plus précisément ils ont
trouvé une façon naturelle de définir
comment le groupe des transformations
linéaire inversible d'efforts mais les
généralisations du déterminant et du
permanent
ces transformations linéaires ont ainsi
transformé des déterminants des formes
et en déterminant déformés et des
permanents déformé en permanent déformée
mais alors l'ensemble des déterminants
déformé forme alors un sou espace
vectoriel qui est lui-même transformé
par le groupe des transformations
linéaire inversible on dit que ce groupe
de transformation l'inr inversible agit
sur l'espace des querelles des
déterminants déformée de la même façon
ce groupe des transformations l'inr
inversible agit sur l'espace électoral
des permanentes des formes et dont le
jargon on parle aussi de représentation
de groupe et on géométrie algébrique
pour comprendre ces représentations de
groupe et est alors utile de les
disséquer c'est-à-dire de découper
autant que possible les espace vectoriel
en morceaux indépendant et insécables
par l'action du groupe de transformation
linéaire chaque morceau insécables est
alors appelée une représentation
irréductible et chaque représentation
irréductibles de l'ensemble des
déterminants des formes et encode d'une
certaine manière les symétries du
déterminant est d'ailleurs petit aparté
ses représentations il ya du clip joue
aussi un rôle majeur en physique des
particules
il détermine
à mal les particules élémentaires et
leurs propriétés le théorème remarquable
de mulets et sony c'est que s'il existe
des représentations irréductibles du
permanent qu'on ne peut pas retrouver
dans leur présentation il ya du crible
du déterminant ou si certaines
représentations irréductibles du
permanent apparaissent plus de fois pour
le permanent que pour le déterminant
alors le permanent aux questions ne peut
pas être un déterminant des formes et
une telle représentation irréductibles
qui prouve l'impossibilité de déformer
le déterminant pour qu'ils calculent un
permanent c'est ce que les deux auteurs
appellent une obstruction une
obstruction et donc une preuve qu'un
déterminant d'une certaine taille ne
peut pas être déformés pour calculer le
permanent d'une autre taille et
intuitivement ça serait parce que le
permanent est trop rigide et ne possède
pas assez de symétrie il reste alors à
démontrer que si le déterminant ne
correspond pas à celui d'une matrice
exponentiellement plus grande que celle
du permanent alors il doit y avoir une
obstruction quelque part depuis la
complexité géométrique est devenue une
quête d'algorithmes de calcul
d'obstruction l'espoir est temps de
trouver un algorithme qui lorsqu on lui
fournit une suite
fdn de taille de matrix 6f de haine ne
crois pas de façon exponentielle alors
l'algorithme exploitera les symétries du
permanent et du déterminant et finira
par trouver une obstruction prouvant
ainsi qu un déterminant de taille n ne
peut pas être une déformation d'un
déterminant de taille f2eg tel est
devenu la priorité de la complexité
géométrique en espérant que ceci
permettra un jour de démontrer pays
différents 2 mp
comme je l'aï dit en introduction la
complexité géométrique est encore en
fait bancal et pleine de trous à combler
on est encore très loin d'une preuve
complète de paix différent de npa
en cela il ya une analogie évidente avec
le cadre de la théorie des cordes
l'une des difficultés que j'ai très
rapidement survolé et comment appliquer
de potentiel résultats de complexité
arithmétique pour un déduire des
résultats de complexité algorithmique
comme p différent de np l'ambition de
mulet c'est de trouver d'autres
fonctions candidate pour remplacer le
permanent est le déterminant qui
imposerait cette fois des limites
algorithmique tout en ayant suffisamment
de symétrie pour se prêter à des preuves
pas obstruction de représentation
irréductibles certains candidats
semblent avoir été identifié désir est
moins pratique à étudier que le
permanent est le déterminant est en
galère déjà avec eux et tout ça pour
simplement démontrer qu'il existe des
puzzles difficile
l'informaticien théoriques sont
décidément une espèce assez bizarre nous
à titre personnel j'ai admet volontiers
qu'il ya une sacrée élégance les
recherches en complexité rigaud et mika
quelque chose de magique et de
terriblement fondamental à mes yeux
après tout on explore la une théorie sur
la limite non seulement de la
connaissance mais aussi et surtout comme
on l'a vu dans la vidéo précédente sur
la limite du connaissable et ça c'est
quand même vraiment trop même si bon à
titre personnel je vous quand même que
je préfère ma recherche sur les
algorithmes bénéfique